عزاء المشاهدين اهلا بكم في هذه المقابله
الخاصه التي نجريها مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتين بلانكين ولدينرافقوا في
هذه الجوله طبعا بداناها في القاهره ثم
سنذهب الى القدس ورام الله مثل السيكوري
ثانك يو ذايمارك
شكرا
الاوقات مناسبه غير مناسبه للعوده لخطط
العمل المشتركه كيف سوف تعملون لمنع ايران
من حيث كان لايران فرصه للعوده لخطه العمل
الشامل المشتركه في الصيف الماضي لكن لسوء
الحظ رفضت ما طرح على الطاوله وما اتفق
عليه من قبل كافه الاطراف
من خلال المقترحات المقدمه
على جمله من الاشياء التي حدثت منذ فتره
واخرها العمليات قمعي المواطنين الابرياء
الشباب والنساء على وجه التح في في ايران
الذين كانوا يدافعون عن حقوقهم الاساسيه
فهناك مساله مهمه تحدث وكنا نراقب ما يتم
من عمليات القمع من قبل النظام وكذلك ايضا
نواجه نراقب ما تقدمه ايران لروسيا في
حربها مع اوكرانيا من مسيرات هذا هو مسار
التركي
ان الطريق الاكثر فعاليه
هي التي كانت موجوده دائما ولكن
العسكريه تحدثهم عن النظام كان يقوم
بتنفيذي احكام المتظاهرين
وبين كيف لكم ان تدعموا
المواطنين الذين كانوا يطالبون بالعون من
الغرب والولايات المتحده كنا مع دول اخرى
نقف ونتحدث بصوت عال مع هؤلاء الذين بكل
بساطه يسعون لجعل اصواتهم مسموعه
وكنا
نقف بجانب هؤلاء الذين تم قمهم من خلال
العقوبات واجراءات التصنيفات المختلفه
ايضا
لمساعده الشعب الايراني
من همم
الولايات المتحده بالتنسيق مع الخليجي
يرمي لردعي ايران كافه هذه الجهود
العسكريه ده هي تعتمد على مساله الردى اي
التحقق من ان من ان من ان الدوله الغاشيه
سوف تفكر مرتين ولا تقدم بعمل خاطئ
وحاولنا نثبت ذلك وان نظهر واننا نقول
نقول اننا مستعدون اذا ما حدث اي عدوان
واذا لم يفلح العدوان سوف نكون على
استعداد للدفاع انفسنا قال الولايات
المتحده دائما
الشعوب التي كانت ترغب بتغير الانظمه
لماذا ليس في ايران اننا ندعمه شعب
الايراني
مثلا ان هذا من صنيعه
انصرف خارج البلاد اي من صنعت الولايات
المتحده فهو فهذا الامر متروك للشعب
الايراني وهم مسؤولون عنه
وقد يعكس مدى الضعف لدى النظم اود ان
انتقل الى الحديث عن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كيف تصفون طبيعه العلاقات مع
السعوديه بعد
قرار اوبك بلس فيما يتعلق بالانتاج قلتم
بانكم سوف تراجعون العلاقات مع السعوديه
لدينا علاقه مهمه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه منذ عقود واجيال من الزمن عبر
ادارات امريكيه مختلفه ومن خلال القيادات
مختلفه في السعوديه انها علاقه ما تزال في
قيد التطور سوف نعمل كل ما بوسه
مصالحنا
مستمر
حول القرار التي اتخذت من قبل ذلك الحين
كانت سعوديه اظهرت
علامات ايجابيه مثل دعمها الواضح
لاوكرانيا في وجهي الغزو الروسي الغاشم
بما يتماشى مع ميثاق الامم المتحده في
مواجهه
العدوان الروسي وتعيدها لقراراته مجلس
الامن وكذلك دعمها للاوضاع الانسانيه في
اليمن هذه الامور مهمه لكنها علاقات مستمر
للتاكد من انها سوف تعمل على تعزيز
المصالح نحن هناك جمله من القضايا في
المنطقه العراق لديه رئيس وزراء جديد
السيد السوداني كيف يمكن
مساعدته اذا كنتم ترغبون في تقويضي
الايرانيه في العراق اولا
انا هنا ان نرغب من هذه العلاقه همم تستمر
في التصدي الابداعش همم
وكنا قد اخذنا بعض الاجراءات التي من
شانها ضماني وتعزيز قدراته قوات الامن
العراقيه ليكون لديها الاستعداد والقدره
لمواجهه داعش لكننا ايضا لدينا شراكه
واسعه النطاق الى حدود اكبر فلدين علاقه
استراتيجيه من خلال العمل مع العراق
ايضا للعراق ان يستمر همم
الانخراط الكامل مع
العلم العربي بصوره كامله ليلعب دورا
كبيرا بحاله مصر في ليبيا هل ترون حكومتا
مختلفتان واحده في بنغادي وفي بن غازي
وثانيه في طرابلس ما ندعمه في هذه المرحله
هو الحجر للتوجه للانتخابات بحيث يكون
هناك حكومه شرعيه وواضحه تعكي
الايراني
الهجوميه التي تقوم بها تركيا في المنطقه
كيف تحقيق مقاربه في هذا الامر مسالتان
عندما يتعلق الامر بسوريا فقط حطينا كافه
الاطراف على عدم الانخراطي في اي متاعب هو
لم نؤيد على العمل العمل الاثر العسكري
التركي في سوريا لانه هذا سوف يؤثر على
المدن وسوف يعرقل الجهود التي ترمي لابعاد
خطر داعش ويبعد و- اا التركيز عن هذا
الامر
ليس من مصلحه فان تم هذا الامر لدى تركيا
مصالح شرعيه ولا يوجد اي جدل حول هذا
الامر لكن هذه المصالح
عشان يعمل العسكري ماذا بشان الاسد
نظام الاسد كنا واضحين فنحن لا نؤيدوا
تطبيع العلاقات شي مع حكومه الاسد
والتحديات هي ان الامم المتحده كانت
اقترحت اجراءات تعتمدوا على خطوه تل
والخطوه وفقا لقارات مجلس الامن خارطه
سياسيه للمستقبل
ننتقل الى رام الله القدس كيف يمكن
التوتر هل ترون ان هناك مقبله كيف يمكن
التوصل لمخزن
سوف نتحدث عنها عن هذا الامر خلال اليومين
المقبلين وكما تعلمون عمليات هجوميه
ارهابيه مروعه خلال الايام الماضيه
وقدناها وتحدث الرئيس بنفسه يعني هوا
راينا فقدان لحياه بعض
المدني وهو امرؤ
الامر الاكثر اهميه في على المدى القصير
هو ان نحاول التوصل الى نوع من الهدوء
لكنني
لكنني في اليومين المقبلين سوف تكون لدي
فرصه للتحدث مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومع
السلطه الفلسطينيه لاسمع من الشعب ايضا
الذي تضرر من هذه الاحباب